thank you the island of Shame gets a new
name little St James that sounds so cute
also known as Epstein
island is getting a major Rebrand it's
located in the Virgin Islands so Mackie
you'd fit right in oh man yeah in your
face 57 it's new owner billionaire
Steven decof paid 60 million for the
pedo property and hopes to transform it
into a luxury Resort apparently spent 10
million on the property and another 50
million on antibacterial
wipes according to the New York Post
much of it will be
refashioned but Epstein's actual former
residence will not be torn down instead
it'll be converted into a luxury hotel
it will have five stars now instead of
just Bill
Gates said the new owner quote I'm
tremendously pleased to be able to bring
an bring the area a worldclass
destination befitting its natural grace
and beauty now there are still two names
remaining on the Epstein Client List
that will remain sealed but we were able
to get a peek at the names which are
still partially redacted here they are
uh and what about the other one oh
yeah still can't make heads or tails but
the question remains will Travelers
really want to visit a resort on an
island that Epstein owned one that was
infamously known for being intense L
depraved what am I saying of course they
will imagine all the Instagram
influencers flocking to get selfies at
exactly the place Bill Clinton may or
may not have taken down a pair of twins
it will be a tourist destination based
on infamy like alcatra Island Pearl
Harbor or the soul bathroom in the
View's green
room but the problem is the name how do
you Market something that was known
previously as pedophile Island well we
came up with some ideas how about about
not pedo
Island definitely not pedo Island no
really this is not pedo Island seriously
guys this is not that island that had
all the
pedophiles and last are you listening no
pedo creeps here on the island and
finally of course Club
Med Kennedy in this day age is the me
first oh that's often the question I
hear uh
is the ick factor a flaw or a draw I
think it's a flaw I this this whole
story is so disturbing and you know I
know there's a lot of like ghost tourism
like people like going to haunted places
like closed down psychiatric hospitals
hoping to channel the spirits and there
may be people who think well no one died
there but I I really feel like these
women who were abused like a part of
them died and I hope they are able
somehow even though they're still living
to haunt anyone who goes there to
exploit the pain they've been I am sure
200 years ago somebody died on the on
this in I'm dying right now somebody
died on this uh ground people die
everywhere can grow up he called it
little St Jeff's like that it's it's so
disgusting the only thing that would
make it better is if we got the full
list of names no we
will at some point you know uh Joe
obviously they're going to need
entertainment down there they'll be
probably flying some comedians down to
perform for like junkets and things like
that would you accept it if the money
was
right yes of course of course I would
Greg talk to my agent uh and to uh to
your point uh if we had to tear down
every place a horrible crime happen in
New York City this this place would look
like koshima in 45 yeah exactly but what
you want to do is just just sterilize
everything on that island including Bill
Gates but I bet a lot of people would
like that torn down so we forget about
what happened and that we haven't uh we
haven't uh prosecuted any of the other
perss uh but we shouldn't try to hide
the ugly parts of our history we
shouldn't be uh tearing down that
building or or statues like Susan
banthony who was at best toist
yeah I've never heard anyone say
that it is uh it is you know what people
don't talk about how she was not hot no
it's true and our audience is not
appreciating that joke the way it should
I agree Susan banthony was at best a six
you guys yeah everyone goes for Betsy
Ross cuz she like
anal
that wasn't in my history book cat you
know uh we talk about like uh places
where the murders took place this is a
lot like he probably got a great deal
cuz you know have you ever gone to look
at like an apartment or a house and they
tell you all that somebody stop right
there no I haven't oh you haven't well
then this is a terrible story but it's
you know you find out maybe the spouse
killed the other spouse in the house or
there was a suicide so he get it for
like a steal I just feel like okay so
it's I don't know that a Rebrand is
going to really be possible like I don't
think they can they can do it as like
another place to take your honeymoon you
know what I mean it's just kind of a
weird place to get a boner I think but
um they could lean into it they could
lean into it and they could be like
listen we know that's bad stuff happened
here or they could do like you know a
whole Epstein theme thing where like
conspiracy nerds would go like you know
drink so strong they killed Jeffrey
Epstein like that kind of a thing or
they need a really good spokesperson
like sha where people just do whatever
they say
right that's true that's true you put
Shaq on something I'm like oh yeah like
everybody likes
Shaq William Dain beo Island sha be like
listen we know but I'm Shaq boom there
you go yeah I could see I could
definitely see that you know Jim why
don't they embrace it it's like people
will go there just to say they were
there like the influencers oh I I got
selfies at pedo Island right I could go
I could I would probably go there just
for the Goof of taking a picture of my
old room
yeah but it really is it is the same
Vibe of going to see that's why they
tore down Jeffrey D's apartment building
right it's or you people drive by where
the Manson Murders happened there's you
can't unsee what happened there so it
literally is just going to be people who
want to be a part of something that was
morbid or historical no matter how bad
it was like aitz has people that will go
and visit it it's because it's something
Terri happened there so that's what this
will draw this won't draw romance and
you can't there's no way to get R this
is see I didn't see it that way I saw
that they would like definitely pave it
over there'd be something there put a
sandals up yeah they put a put up a
sandals you know inclusive I don't know
I mean maybe I'm maybe I'm just from a
different age I guess they big slug Lin
is going be at least we're not Staten
Island hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else